hello everyone and welcome to our
webinar on how to build
number-one-ranked digital transformation
programs with value colleges we're going
to be sharing how your institution can
bridge the critical skills gap by
offering digital transformation courses
now since 2014 the office of continuing
studies at Duke University is
successfully utilized elearning programs
to bridge this gap with simply learn
providing skills training and a variety
of digital economy technologies through
online self-paced video courses and live
virtual classrooms it's a proven way to
immediately add extended education
offerings for career focused individuals
and companies seeking to upskill their
employees so with that we can start
beginning I just want to introduce our
our panelists today our expert guests
for this webinar include dr. Gabe Sidney
Morris the assistant professor of
English at Johnson C smith University
and a higher education consultant with
more than 15 years of experience in
Arwen public research institutions as
well as Duke University we'll also be
joined by Whitney Murphy program manager
Duke continuing studies and Logan
Halliwell who is our academic programs
and partnerships manager here simply
learn to give us an overview and we'll
just start off with Logan hello Logan
how are you doing today again thank you
very much for the introduction and hello
to the audience thank you for joining us
it's been kind of a really interesting
journey working here to build such a
great program it's been a pleasure to
work with Duke and we're very happy to
have it had the involvement of value
colleges as well who was actually the
one who had us kind of do a ranking in
this and this program the way we get
there and I think that the best place to
start is to take a look at the market
and what we can do from simple learners
perspective is kind of start with why
we're in business and that is to help
businesses compete and succeed in the
digital economy what does that mean
well the digital economy is typically
content areas that can be defined by a
couple of different areas
it's either fast-moving it's an emerging
process
such technology is changing over there
there's a new technology that's coming
out and it sometimes it's a challenge to
figure out how to integrate that into
your business process so because of that
there's not very well-defined training
opportunities for learners to start
learning about that unless they're in
the industry and so when you have these
learners that are trying to assist and
work with these businesses to pursue
that new opportunity oftentimes there's
challenges and when you when you're that
learner and you're trying to dig in and
trying to better yourself and and you
know there's opportunity out there
it results in a gap where you know you
have the urge to learn you know you need
to learn it's just challenging outside
looking in about where you go to get
that sort of training typically you
think of a university partner and so you
would go and look for the university to
to help you with that goal that career
path towards meaningful employment and
what we're seeing in the market is that
when these three entities don't
communicate well you end up with the
critical skills gap with you know that's
the buzzword that everyone is so
familiar with when we look at simply
learn we take a look at who those
participants are in that digital economy
and so these are some of our
organizations and partners that we've
worked with and it just goes to show it
is a global problem everybody is looking
to train and more efficient ways so that
they can compete for these new
opportunities so with that where does
simply learn fit in with this wonderful
program so we our catalog is broadly
speaking focused directly in that
digital economy content areas we like to
call it digital transformation
technologies and so what we do is we
have our own line of consumer business
where we help learners professionals
that are mid-career professors typically
are looking for career change or career
entry to get to those skills in place so
that they can connect with the
businesses and the businesses will come
to us and they'll be looking at it and
they'll say hey you know we need we have
a digital initiative we want to roll out
can you help us and so we're
communicating with the businesses there
to help them support their emerging
needs
and then you have a university such as
Duke continuing studies where they they
want to help and assist with these
learners and there's a lot of challenges
here in areas for miscommunication so we
simply learn being in between both the
individual learner and the international
business community we can provide some
lessons learned and an ongoing
conversation with to where Duke can take
those lessons learn to figure out how
they're going to provide value and then
communicate that to the learner and then
in that way we all work together
collaboratively to focus on reducing
that critical skills gap and so how to
simply learn do that broadly speaking
it's through two areas so our first is
our content and that's that's kind of
one of the key aspects of what the value
that we bring to the equation is we
align our content in various different
categories as a category or an emerging
process is developed it takes a certain
amount of time for it to kind of
coalesce into something that we can
coherently call a category so our newest
one artificial intelligence and machine
learning and digital selling are coming
out of the results of you know about 18
months 24 months the last two years of
technology advancements where you're now
seeing that as an area of focus and
those job roles are coming out what that
means is it justifies us created
category and there's also when we create
a category there's also an opportunity
to engage with leading global
influencers so with the instance of
artificial intelligence we've engaged
with the number one rated a individual
Mike Tamir to kind of help us with our
category and then guide us through kind
of course selection etc as we as the
category matures and so that's where
simply learn kind of uses its market
awareness to identify emerging
categories aligned with them with global
leaders and then start working through a
coherent way to to build out an offering
that supports those career strategies of
learners now how do we support that how
do we deliver that once it's built we
have a proprietary LMS that we've built
that focuses one on self-paced learning
for the flexibility of delivering its
mobile-optimized you can use it out of
your out of your smartphone but also an
opportunity for instructor led live
virtual classrooms
what we've noticed is that when you add
that live component it's it's really
powerful as a tool to encourage course
completion we also have a focus on
developing opportunities for case study
and project orgs apply practice or
simulation and you know it's always
aligned to that real or denis that
real-world application all of our
content is aligned to industry standard
where possible vendor standard we're not
and from that perspective what we like
to say is we will get you the learnings
but we'll also get you some of that
practical applications so that when you
land in your job you're you're ready
it's not you you've passed the test and
now you're not certain necessarily how
to use what you've learned but know the
skills that you're learning have an
immediate practical application so you
might say oK we've talked a lot about
emerging technology and you talked about
all this new stuff where why we
understand that but is there data behind
that and so this is a snapshot of when
we look at our category growth and our
participants that are actually of the
number of enrollments we have by
category in last year and so what we've
seen in these emerging process areas
we've seen a lot of really strong growth
and interest in our big data and
analytics or mobile the cloud one is
quite high we've opened up a couple of
new offerings there and both Azure and
Google and so we're seeing a lot of
explosive growth there but yes digital
marketing has been strong it's been
growing significantly for multiple years
as you can also see with the popularity
of the Duke program and then when we
look at the traditional categories
I wouldn't necessarily that say that
they're any less important it's just one
of those things where there's a stronger
interest on the emerging side because so
much of the new opportunity and the
economy is in those categories and then
so you might say you know okay you see
growth in these categories well who's
doing that who's enrolling then what we
look at is by category we we ask them
this is all volunteered information we
ask you know who is taking this this
course and so when we look at the these
courses by category we can see that
there's Java's the reason that this is
important is because we can understand
who in the economy is needing these
skills so that when we start doing any
sort of you know program analysis or we
start doing the program design we can
understand who
needs this training and oftentimes
you'll see you know as you look at the
age brackets as well you'll see if that
made career professional and it's either
somebody who is making an industry
change or a career change or they're
looking for career advancement and so
that is also supported when we ask the
question how his digital training helped
you you know we want to know does it
work does it does it has it had a
positive effect on your work life and
what we're finding is that you know 94%
of learners are saying that it has been
effective when they completed it it's
given them more confidence
its enhance their performance at work
and very few people say that's not
helpful
and so that kind of demonstrates the
value of flexible online learning in a
real concrete way
following up on that what we found is
that when we ask the question you know
how does digital training impact your
career we find that yes it not only does
it make your job your day-to-day duties
easier and more effective it actually
has a positive effect on your career
either in new jobs promotions or raises
and pay and really what what we like to
take this as a lesson learned is and
kind of the key insights that we're
observing in this area is that when you
focus on these emergent processes and
technologies and you enable individuals
to compete it betters their lives and so
that's what I think the big takeaway
from where we have programs like this as
we find out ok what makes the learners
life better what opens up opportunity
for them and how do we effectively and
efficiently provide that training for
them to empower themselves to pursue
those better in more meaningful career
so then we ask you know that's that's
all well and good from Superman's
perspective but who are the academic
learners and with that I'd like to bring
in Gabe here he would be much more of an
expert on you know who these sorts of
programs can provide value to so Gabe if
you want to jump on Thank You Owen as
Dan mentioned before I'm Gabe C Lee
Morris and I'm an assistant professor of
English but I'm here today as a
representative value colleges which is
an independent ranking and information
sight for college students and with
value colleges in recent years we've
also been very interested in emerging
fields and emerging technologies and
we've been trying to lead the way in
information and rankings about programs
like big data like digital marketing and
in looking for non-traditional ways of
educating students and educating a
workforce value College's primary
audience is generally first-generation
students who tend to come from a
low-income or a minority or an
underrepresented population group or
working adults the people that Logan has
been talking about those who are
changing careers those who are having
credentials for promotion or for
advancement those who are returning to
the workforce or returning to school in
order to return to the workforce and
value colleges in emphasis for these
students is the focus on schools and
degrees that pay off what these
demographics have in common is that
these are people who do not have the
luxury of going to college for college's
sake as traditionally we've got of as
college as a way of exploring what you
want to do with your life or who you
want to be when you grow up or who you
are first-generation students working
adult students tend to have in common
the fact that they need to see and in
the goal and they need to see how
college is going to pay offered them in
a real-world tangible way whether that
is social mobile
leti or an entry into a professional
career or if that way is promotion in
their current career a career change or
advancement and more income
well we yeah awesome thank you for that
so so that that's a good you know intro
on who are the academic learners and I
think that's also a great segue to bring
in Whitney Whitney you've uh you've been
with the program from the start and you
had some thoughts about how do kind of
looks at designing things so with that I
guess I'll hand it off to you Thank You
Logan as mentioned earlier I'm Whitney
Murphy I'm the program manager here at
DU continuing studies and I handle a
number of programs here but most notably
our digital marketing program big data
certificate and our newest program in
digital selling here at Duke when we
think about working with a partner
really our first priority our number one
priority is going to be setting up
setting up new programming to make sure
that we are authentic to our brand you
know Duke has a very strong brand name
we want to make sure that we maintain
that anytime we decide to offer a new
program we also aim to make that program
the most comprehensive in the business
because we wouldn't be Duke if we didn't
want to be the best of everything right
I mean it needs to also be extremely
high quality though that again it
reflects the Duke standards for
excellence
ideally any new program should also be
aligned in some way to a national
certification in our case we align the
digital media and marketing program to
the OMC p om CP which stands for the
online marketing certified professional
certification and that to us suggests
that the content is not only
comprehensive but also actually relevant
to the skills that are needed to work in
the industry
one of the reasons that we chose to go
with an external partner in the case of
our more tech related programs is really
because we just can't keep up with the
pace of change in these industries and
if we want to stay relevant and stay
of course we need to stay relevant to
these current market trends and make
sure that we have the most up-to-date
content possible and thats where simply
learn comes into play another important
thing to consider when working with a
partner is just to make sure that you
differentiate yourself in our case
simply Lauren does offer similar
products and so we've made it a point
from the very beginning to set up
differentiators for what we offer so
that we can obviously stand out and then
of course there's more to consider when
you're working with a partner or just
building a new program in general and
the very first and foremost thing that
comes to mind is doing you're not just
doing your research but building the
program there's a number of things to
think about market research is one of
the first things we usually do and that
is basically making sure we've done our
homework so that we know what kind of
skills are in demand and we can align
our program with opportunity in the
market what we do when we do our
research because after all Duke is a
research-based institution we expect to
see how many total jobs are available as
well as how many are going to go
unfilled
in certain subject areas and this helps
us really determine where to focus our
energies so that we can have an impact
on supporting the critical skills gap we
also really need to find a lot of that
information I was going to say we all.we
rely on simply learn a lot for this
information as they do studies into the
market and are constantly scrolling
through a lot of the hiring websites and
things like that and right now the hot
topics are of course digital marketing
you know big data machine learning and
digital selling and everything that all
things tech related is what we're seeing
and you have particular websites that
you look for like glass or indeed you
have any other ones that you prefer hmm
I think those are the top ones for us
and once we know oh actually we like the
US News & World Report as well they have
a lot of information about the kind of
subject areas that are going to be in
demand you know in the next you know
five ten years and so we do rely on that
as well
and once we know sort of what's hot and
what popular we can focus our energies
on determining who our ideal student is
in most cases our folks are career
changers they're also folks looking to
build their resumes through new skills
or even people who are looking for what
we call a total digital skills makeover
so someone who has been working in any
industry for let's say ten to twenty
years and just really needs to
completely reinvigorate their skillset
and learn some of these digital
transformation skills so that's that's
kind of our people in a nutshell which
means that we really do have people of
all ages experience levels and walks of
life in our programs which is pretty
neat and of course continuing on the
research train when a student is
considering a program that they might
want to take there's a lot of things to
think about I'm going to ask a lot of
questions here so what can you afford to
spend on the program obviously prices
vary greatly you know from a two-hour
online program to a two week or even
two-year online program so you just
never know you know it just all depends
on like the amount of time that you want
to spend and how much money you can
spend it is the program online or is it
in the classroom or some combination of
both there's obviously online is quite
popular but people do still like to have
that interaction with an instructor you
have to be anywhere at a specific time
like in the case of either an actual
classroom program or a live virtual
program so you know do you have to fit
it into your schedule at a specific time
or can you be there whenever you want
who are the instructors and you actually
get anytime
with them to ask questions what type of
learning opportunities are included for
example are there labs and simulations
where you can practice what you've
learned after all oh we we really
believe that hands-on is really the best
way to learn if you want to actually
have a set of skills that you can take
and use in a job we also you should also
ask is there any live interaction and
that's that's a key thing to know and
lastly does this program have any
reviews you can see before signing up I
think that's that's also becoming
increasingly important in the day of you
know this day and age of Google and
reviews all over the web so if you yes I
wonder if you could expand seeing as a
lot of people are attracted to the
convenience of self-paced online
learning what is the benefit of live
interaction if you could expand on that
I think I can jump in with some data
points what we've seen you know from
from a pretty large sample size on the
self-paced side
industry standards are typically you
know somewhere between 15 and 25% course
completion rates when you add a live
instructional component whether it's you
know on-site or in a virtual classroom
what we've observed is that our first
completion rates have gone north of 70%
so I think that's just a testament to
you know you always hear the word
engagement from you know the learning
field but but it's it's a testament to
the strength of that kind of human
interaction when you're learning you
know everyone needs a hug every once in
a while and if you don't have a live
person on the other side who can look at
you and see okay that person needs a hug
you know and then you lose out on some
of that engagement opportunity so I
think that's that's definitely backed up
by some strong data points thank you
long and I appreciate you answering that
question for me I think you do art and I
know that's it
I the last thing here is I just would
say be sure to consider both your own
limitations as well as the limitations
of the school you choose because really
not all programs can be all things to
all students so when you think about
signing up for a program there's a few
more things you have to ask yourself as
if you haven't asked
self enough already you need to ask does
the program provide any printable
materials like slides and study guides
that you can keep after your program has
expired because many of these programs
are time limited and Duke does provide
you with both in our technical based
programs
Dennis thing is the programmer
University offer any resume assistance
or career guidance for example and Duke
actually can't do either because we
don't have the support structures in
place to do so but other schools may be
able to provide that as a value-add so
just keep that in mind does the program
provide you with a specific credential
or certificate some will do both but
most will only do one and Duke actually
will provide you with a certificate of
completion that shows you met the
requirements for our programs our
curriculum is also aligned with the OU
mCP requirements that again is the
online marketing certified professional
but you don't actually earn that
certification
when you finish our program if I could
jump in again Whitney how does Duke
design the difference between a
certificate and a certification
absolutely that's actually one of my top
asked questions gave there thank you a
certificate is typically the actual
physical piece of paper or a
downloadable version of said paper
that's issued by a university or even a
company that provides educational
programming and that shows that the
student completed a particular program
they might have had a attendance
requirement or a specific grade they
needed to achieve and that certificate
indicates that that student has met
those requirements and typically a
certificate does not expire now a
certification is something completely
different it's a much more formal
process in many cases and it requires
that the person take an exam that will
test on his or her knowledge of a given
subject area so that exam has a fee
associated with it you would want to
register months to weeks in advance
and you go and sit and take this test
it's in a timed environment and you earn
at the end if she's doing you pass the
test you are in a designation that
designation in this case could be the OM
CP or if you're in the HR industry it
could be the Sherm CP for example and
any certification is going to also
require that you also renew the
certification every couple of years it's
different for each certification and
that the person is also maintaining
their level of knowledge by attending
classes for example that are going to
earn them continuing education credits
in that arena so hopefully that answers
your question Gabe alright so in terms
of what we think of as success and what
success looks like to us here at Duke I
think what makes the Duke program
particularly successful and and worth
our high ranking is a couple of things
one is that we have a truly dedicated
support from the University both on a
technical side and on the administrative
side so that students have a
relationship with the program manager
which in this case is myself and feel
comfortable that their needs will be met
and their desires and unfortunately yes
sometimes complaints will be heard
ideally this dedicated support person
you know should ideally be one person a
single point of contact who also has
detailed program knowledge and that
really helps the students feel more like
they're going to get the answers to the
questions they need and be taken care of
and this really ensures that the student
feels like a person and not a number and
lastly the university should own the
program management not the partner so
while the partner simply learn in this
case is extremely important and we could
not do this without them they need to
take the back seat and let Duke sit in
the driver's seat in this situation and
in our case that's exactly what happens
and we are ultimately fully responsible
to our students for both their positive
and their negative experiences and this
really does encourage a very
wrong student engagement from the
University so that students truly like
they're having a Duke University
experience which is what's the most
important to us but I think that's all
I've got
yeah wedding I got once thought yeah on
that you know from up from the the
students learning perspective or kind of
their experience when they ask questions
on it they're talking to you before
they've even made the choice so they're
learning about the program from you and
then once they enroll they're still
you're kind of guiding the whole
experience from start to finish is it
that's a correct understanding logan
that's exactly right
so I am like their concierge to their
learning experience sometimes like to
think of it it's a very important role
and I think it really does make the
partnership it's very seamless so the
student really does feel like they're
getting that kind of a Duke touch and
Duke experience so you know you've heard
from me and from Duke what we think
success looks like and we what why we
think were the best but I'm going to
turn it over to Gabe so he can tell you
what value colleges really look for in a
successful program thank you whizzing so
the title of this webinar is building a
top ranked program and value colleges
has ranked Dukes digital marketing as
our number one program of its kind and
so I would like to talk a little bit
about how we came to that conclusion so
value colleges are the tagline is the
best colleges the lowest costs the
highest returns and as I mentioned our
readership our intended audience since
tend to be people who care about their
costs and their returns we're very
interested and have been interested for
a while in the emerging fields which
means that in a lot of cases there's not
a great deal of formal traditional
attention from colleges and universities
colleges and universities are
notoriously slow to catch up with
changes in technology changes in the job
market itself so we've had we have found
ourselves looking quite often at
non-traditional
ways of educating and training in these
emerging areas we look for schools and
degrees that pay off for their students
we generally define value with three
different sets of criteria three
different metrics and one is reputation
that generally comes from sources the
ranking sources such as US News and
World Report as Whitney was mentioning
The Times The Times world ranking
Washington Monthly publications like
that
that do research on purely how a college
university is perceived because
reputation is a value reputation has a
real world and a real world job market
value the name on a resume can open or
close doors as every job seeker is aware
of obviously an institution like Duke
has an extremely high name brand
recognition and extremely high
reputation and to be able to see a
non-traditional program a certificate
program from Duke carrying that
reputation that has real market impact
we also tend to look at cost and that is
as we said as I said before a real
consideration for our audience
especially when we're especially when
we're talking about working adults
returning students non-traditional age
to working professional students by and
large they are paying their own way
through a program so cost is a real
consideration whether they are going to
have to go into debt for it whether they
are going to have to have tighten up
their belts for a year or two and
whether that cost alongside the cost of
time and energy
is going to produce a return on
investment the working adults the
non-traditional students that a program
like Dukes program Dukes Continuing
Studies program appeals to need to see
that everything that they're doing
whether it is taking time away from
their jobs taking time away from their
family taking time away from their
recreation if that's going to have a
real return and we look at things like
big scale things like iPads to see what
kinds of returns students are getting
primarily primarily what they can expect
to make coming out of a program what
they can expect to make mid-career how
much more they will make with a
particular degree or program from a
particular college or university as
opposed to if they had gone on without
it and those three together we tend to
take in equal measure as defining what
we think of as being valued so one of
the considerations one of the questions
that a working adult or a returning
student is going to have to consider as
Whitney said you have to do your
research in one area that of real
consideration is whether to get a degree
or whether to go to continuing education
for a certificate or some other sort of
or some other sort of credential a
degree in general obviously has its
upsides and downsides is going to cost a
lot more to get into to get a full
degree whether that is finishing a
bachelor's degree or getting a master's
degree obviously it's going to take
longer to get directly into the field
because a degree takes longer again
whether it's finishing a bachelor's
degree or getting a master's degree
that's an investment of two three years
or more whereas the certificate is going
to be much shorter the other thing about
a degree program especially for working
at
students is that to get a bachelor's
degree and even to get a master's degree
you're going to have to take a lot of
courses that are not directly relevant
to what you're studying or to your
career goals and in a traditional
thinking or in traditional understanding
of college that's fine because you're
getting well-rounded and you are you
know making yourself a more
knowledgeable person but for those who
are already working in the field or who
are trying to change their careers that
can be perceived as a waste of time so
it's important to recognize that in a
degree program you're going to take
things that are not relevant to you on
the other hand it's very important to
remember and to take into consideration
that a degree is going to carry a higher
value on your resume the degree is going
to look better on paper than a
certificate to employers and that's just
a fact of the job market and the fact of
how we perceive different kinds of
education slogan Thanks now on the other
hand the professional certificate for
working adults for job changers is going
to be much more directed and it's going
much more targeted to the career path as
Logan and Whitney we're both talking
about in developing the program at Duke
they take into consideration what that
particular field of business is looking
for they take into consideration what
real employers are asking for what they
want their employees to be able to do so
that very direct link between business
and the industry that you want to go
into in the program that you're taking
can be very valuable a stiff that also
gets you into the field faster plain and
simple it can be a year or even less to
get a certificate a continuing ed
certificate
while it may not carry the same value as
a degree which I just was talking about
that in itself is industry defendant in
a lot of industries the primary interest
is the primary concern is whether you
can do the job or not and that's
especially true of emerging technologies
and emerging fields like digital
marketing a certificate tells an
employer that you have had training in
this field and that you can do the job
so when a working adult when a
non-traditional student is considering
this question whether to go with a
degree program or whether to go with
continuing education the main question
to ask is what do you need to do what
you want if what you want is to get into
the field more quickly with the
information that you need to know to do
the job or to advance in your career a
certificate makes sense whether so yeah
I think I think we'll start kind of
wrapping it up here shortly but Gabe I
think you've covered a lot of the points
to choose from when choosing a program
and you know I think you know these are
questions that anyone should rightly ask
when they're looking at investing in
self development and kind of how that
aligns to their goals for for a career
progression how effects how to
effectively leverage your investment
once you're in there and where where are
you perceiving fine value I think
personally the strength of the program
is you know when when you have that
element like Whitney a program manager
who's going to walk you through the
whole process that high-touch concierge
level of service I think that's a huge
differentiator and it's one of those
things that I think is is oftentimes
missed is hey who's going to help me
push through the program who's going to
help me you know if I have a question
oftentimes sometimes it's not the
instructor per se but it might be the
program manager and so in that sense I
mean Whitney if you want to talk a
little bit I'm sure you have some
anecdotes about pushing students through
to finish or because I know you stay
pretty engaged with your students that's
thanks Logan I stay more engaged than
our
- yes and constantly going to bat for
them and trying to figure out ways to
make the system that we have even more
user-friendly and provide even more
opportunities to stay on help them stay
on track essentially I've recently
created a little introductory video of
myself sort of guiding students through
the coursework as they're first getting
started to give that extra level of
touch and I have a very detailed
spreadsheet where I keep up with our
students activities and do basically I
send a manual reminder to students you
know after about six months and then
again about one month before they expire
and offer my assistance in determining
how much they need to be doing in the
next few months to finish the program
etc so I try to make myself as available
as possible for situations like that
which happens pretty frequently right
right I'm sure that makes everyone feel
good
particularly the participants in fact we
got together with Whitney and some
alumni and we captured some of those
sentence sentiments so I'd like to play
a video cuz you can hear us talk about
the program but it's it's I think it's
always best to talk about the people
who've been through the program so this
is a video of some alumni that we put
together about their experiences going
through the program and what it's done
for them just one administrative know if
you're on a cell phone call in it might
be a little bit echoey and the video may
be a little bit choppy due to bandwidth
but the audio should be just fine so
with that we'll listen to this short
video and then we will wrap it all up
and open up the floor for questions this
is Duke University
[Music]
hi my name is Kristen Fox I work for a
while Disney Company in Los Angeles
California hi my name is Joseph yameen
and I'm from Caracas Venezuela I am al
Freeman or seven years old from outer
space Georgia hi I'm Michelle Nunn 25
from Atlanta Georgia when I'm Sarah
fullen I'm the head of marketing for a
global eyewear company my name is Scott
Wolter a web content specialist hi I'm
patty from Chicago and I completed the
Duke digital media and marketing program
I decided I needed to specialize in
something to help set me apart from the
crowd the Duke program offered courses
in SEO SEM digital analytics email
marketing all in one convenient location
one of the things I learned how much
time is it going to take I have enough
time to complete the course what you
need to understand is it's really about
30 hours a month the best thing about it
was the flexibility allowed me to log on
at night time into the classes give me
more time to accomplish wrinkles I
needed an intensive program blender I
could go beyond the buzz words you will
be so surprised at how much you don't
know I was able to take that knowledge
those tools and build a company which
I've now sold so the digital media and
marketing program has forever changed my
life
I'm also the mum of two busy children
and this course gave me the ability to
learn digital marketing concepts within
the tight restraints of my schedule
after we were boarding I guess it's
given me the opportunity opening new
doors that I haven't really thinking
about before so it's definitely a very
exciting experience what I like most
about the digital media marketing
certification was delving into all those
disciplines to help create a more
well-rounded market so many capable not
only at providing the content for a
multi-channel marketing campaign but
also someone capable of distributing it
measuring it testing it and out
I wanted to take what I love which was
marketing but I wanted to do it on my
own terms and the Duke program allows me
to do that so now my mornings was just a
little bit different I was able to do it
on this couch while my little kids slept
and felt like I could apply it pretty
much immediately it's every day at work
and after the program I decided that
with my day job inspire me I start my
own digital marketing agency so whether
you're a busy mom we began just a busy
person looking for that course to
educate yourself on digital marketing to
stay on the pulse of what's going on
this course definitely delivered that
for you
I've read the Ranger Trail it's a really
great program good luck awesome
well that's that about wraps up the meat
potatoes are the presentation so I want
to thank the audience for sticking with
us through to the end we'll be hanging
out here until we see everybody go to
field any questions but again thank you
very much for joining and thank you
Whitney
and thank you Gabe for joining us as
well great and thank you Logan
elect so we do have one question for the
team here already and is there a is
there a difference between what
businesses are looking for and what
learners are looking for I can answer
that one yeah there there is typically
when you look at a learner's goal it's
as Whitney mentioned it's aligned to
certification so you kind of the the
success metric would be course
completion so this do we complete the
course because you can't really say hey
I took half of course when you're you
know into to get into a new career or
something like that and so I would say
Morty it's either going to be course
completion or certification or if they
already have the job then they're just
looking for skills so but we would call
that upskilling and then from a business
perspective it kind of depends what
they're using it for if they're using it
for and they're using it for a digital
initiative so say I've decided to move
to the organization to the cloud and we
want to you know train our
except on specific leaders your micro
Microsoft is your you know we're going
with AWS and we need to you know do a
comprehensive training program but we
don't necessarily need everyone
certified they might you know need two
or three of those skills in they one
program so for their perspective it's
not so much the impetus on course
completion it's more I need this
specific skill so I guess it would
depend on on what the goals are for each
hope that answers the question
great thanks very much sorry Logan did
that cut you off oh no not at all I was
just seeing a wooden your David any
thoughts from updating no I will but we
agree with you great well that seems to
be all the questions we have coming in
for now and I just want to thank
everyone again for joining us thank you
gave thank you Whitney and of course
again Logan now for those of you who
registered through WebEx please keep an
eye out on your email because we will be
sending you a follow up soon that has a
recording of this videos that you can
review at your convenience and of course
feel free to share it if you have any
other questions feel free to contact us
that here are the your the email
addresses for all of us on the on the
panel and thank you very much for
joining us and we'll see you next time
thank you thank you Dan thank you hi
there if you liked this video subscribe
to the simply learn youtube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here